[Música]
continuamos hablando de nuestro tema del
día donde vamos a analizar la
investigación periodística llamada los
papeles de pandora tras este nuevo
escándalo la unión europea ya retiró de
la lista de paraísos fiscales a las
islas seychelles anguila y dominica lo
que ha generado críticas luego de las
revelaciones de los papeles de pandora
que expusieron los secretos financieros
de cerca de 35 jefes de estado y también
de gobierno varios de ellos ya han
respondido ya sea negando que estén
implicados en esto asegurando que van
ellos a hacer sus propias
investigaciones por ejemplo el rey
abdullah de jordania negó que tenga
compañías offshore para esconder sus
lujosas propiedades también lo hizo el
primer ministro de pakistán y el kremlin
que negó las acusaciones de que el
presidente vladimir putin le haya
comprado una lujosa propiedad de mónaco
a una mujer con la que tenía una
relación para ello quiero saludar en
este momento a georgina cerega ya es
periodista en el país de españa y
también en mexico y el país de américa
colaboradora del equipo mexicano de los
o pandora paper ser gracias georgina por
estar aquí en directo américa muy buen
día le pregunto cómo hicieron esta
investigación que tan difícil fue además
buenos días fue una investigación larga
un proceso bastante largo para algunos
periodistas duro dos años para otros dos
un poco menos en nuestro caso con una
investigación de diez meses en la que
bueno revisamos el 11 no revisamos 11,9
millones eso es lo que tienen la base de
datos pero si revisamos muchos
incontables a esta altura de documentos
que fueron filtrados al consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación y que nos nos llevó mucho
tiempo revisar para encontrar nombres a
ver quién estaba en esos catorce
despachos que filtraron los documentos
y además para entender las historias
porque
hay un montón de nombres y sé que es
normal que nos alertemos cuando
escuchamos un nombre
pero cada uno difiere de lo que ha hecho
en los ciertos paraísos fiscales hay
gente que ha abierto una obra y nunca la
ha usado hay gente que ha hecho todo
tipo de movimientos hay casos de
corrupción ligados a estos despachos
entonces hay historias montón difíciles
de entender difíciles de desagregar pero
pero bueno eso hemos estado hacen
nuestros meses
georgina eso le quería preguntar no
todas las personas que se encuentran en
esa lista han cometido algún acto ilegal
digamos
no abrir una opción no es ilegal y es lo
primero que decimos de todas formas
también decimos que no sea ilegal no
quiere decir que esté bien
pero pero más allá de eso me parece que
es un debate que va más allá de la
legalidad o la ilegalidad que los van
der papers nos vienen a mostrar que
existe un sistema que sigue trabajando
para esconder el dinero de muy poco el
1% del mundo entonces no solo hay gente
que esconde su dinero sino que alrededor
de ellos se forma una industria que se
dedica a esconder el dinero de ellos
georgina le quiero preguntar la
diferencia de los pandora de los panamá
papers además aprovechó para preguntarle
si no sé si tuvo la oportunidad de
trabajar también en la investigación de
los panamá papers
no es para nada pp no estaba pero esta
es una investigación muy parecida a los
cánones papers
un poco más grande en cuanto a
documentos de hecho internamente decimos
que son unos panamá papers y anabólicos
flow de digamos un poco más grandes y
claro
2.0
y en realidad porque trae más documentos
y porque los pone más papers hablamos de
un despacho que era en el musac sonseca
el despacho de donde se habían filtrado
los documentos y en este caso son 14
despachos entonces hay variedad de
historias porque en los 14 despachos
estos montos alrededor de todo el mundo
y no solamente en panamá o en one en
américa
pero bueno es un poco similar va en la
misma línea y también nos trae
un vistazo cómo se ha comportado este
mundo después de los panamá papers que
ha pasado que ha cambiado en
la vida real en realidad porque más allá
de las promesas que nos han hecho hoy y
lo que dijeron los políticos razón 6 en
esto nos viene a mostrar que qué poco
cambio en la vida real les olvidó decir
que tanto ha cambiado el mundo después
de los panamá papers además georgina le
quiero preguntar cuál es el fin de esta
investigación simplemente que el mundo
conozca la verdad guayota hay algo
detrás también de esta investigación esa
con qué fin ustedes hacen esto
nosotros como periodistas cuando tenemos
la información cuando recibimos la
información la analizamos encontramos la
historia no no lo hacemos con el
objetivo de atacar a alguien en
particular en este tipo de filtraciones
y este tipo de investigaciones nos dan
nos abren la puerta como nunca antes a
un mundo que es muy difícil de llegar
que unos pocos solamente serán si uno no
tiene cierta cantidad de dinero cierto
capital no llega a este mundo no lo
conoce y no sabe qué hay detrás de esas
puertas entonces este tipo de
investigaciones nos vienen demostrar es
este mundo este sistema que existe por
más que nosotros no podamos verlo
excepto en estas pocas ocasiones como
los panamá petter sus paredes papers o
las pandoras vienen otros papers podrían
filtrarse otros documentos además le
quiero preguntar como cómo se filtran
este tipo de información confidencial y
además cuando llega a ustedes cómo hacen
para diversificar el trabajo es decir yo
agarro ese tema usted tú agarras este
tema
bueno en realidad se trabaja con medios
a nivel local entonces el consorcio
recibe los documentos de una fuente
anónima
de la que ni siquiera la mayoría de
nosotros conocemos de dónde viene
entonces incluso se anote no podríamos
decirlo pero pero muchos ni siquiera
sabemos solamente lo sabe el consorcio y
en ese sesión con sus se organiza los
medios de comunicación e invita a medios
de comunicación y nosotros nos sumamos
de manera local en el caso del país nos
sumamos con un equipo en españa y cuando
el equipo de españa vio que había
muchísimos nombres y muchísimas
historias en américa latina
decidió sumar a un equipo en mexico y
ahí es cuando entramos nosotros
en estirar esto también entonces la
investigación se lleva de manera local
acá en méxico nos hemos dedicado a
contar las historias mexicanas y en
españa' las españolas y kiss y a su vez
replicar las historias que otros
compañeros han investigado y en el
escrito en otros países pues georgina
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
y pues entender un poco cómo se hizo
esta investigación de los o pandora
papers gracias por su tiempo nuevamente
jordina gracias a ustedes gracias por la
invitación